[Music]
you got kind of a cool start which is
you played basketball in Nike ads yeah I
got a buddy of mine invited me to go to
this Nike tournament to do tricks and I
won that event doing a trick where I
could spin a ball put the ball in the
pen and put the pen in my mouth and the
ball would keep spinning Wow and I won
it and Nike said listen we'd love for
you to be a bunch of a part of our
commercials and our campaigns I did that
that got me in front of the camera and
and it up here now so you're you're a
very good basketball player I'm decent
and what's a little upsetting I got to
be honest is when I meet someone like
you who's six four and I hear you don't
play basketball no and it's one of the
few things if I had like five inches if
I had your height the potential is
endless who knows like I might have been
I might have not been yet might have
been an NBA who knows yeah I think you
first of all you're doing fine second of
all thank you
second of all I hear the ladies are
quite forward with you is that true
she is actually you know I just got on
social media recently and and so I think
that's been the most forward I've
actually received you know like I got
one tweet where a woman was like you
know love gang-related can we gangbang
and what was the answer yes okay maybe
just take the pill yeah our by the way I
just heard that interview yeah he
dropped some gems yes good some really
this is good this is good advice for me
I'm not hoping I'm not gonna need that
stuff in awhile for a while now gesture
my way
I don't to get out of the line of fire
he'll be like well one day when I'm in
pain yeah when I have to take the Conan
pill 30 milligrams of Conan she said
Simmons I mean the timing of it in the
end this you know the the foreplay all
stuff we're gonna go I are gonna have to
know many many years from now both of us
we won't be needing them we won't no no
no no but uh so you know it's social
media you bring this up yeah media
people I think people can be much more
forward on social media so you have yeah
I drop position
I got proposition it's it's very new to
me I'm kind of still figuring it out I I
noticed you have a really large amount
of followers and and I heard you weren't
that big of a fan of it I'm really not
that crazy about it but I'm trying to
figure it out no I love the actually
being in social media but I don't if
someone you know comes on to me on the
Internet
it's a great it happens right I mean it
well I'm trying to get it to happen it
hasn't happened yet but I'm trying to
encourage here's the deal what if I can
help you with that and you can help me
getting some followers I just started I
don't have enough followers I knew how
many followers do you have
none basically I don't know 2000 or
something not a lot I know I need your
help okay and so I can help put on you
know send you some aggressive people
some aggressive women to send you some
aggressive message
I was kidding I really can't be into
that because of the old marriage
but in the commercial break we'll talk